you ever watched this guy on the uh
internet
his name is uh David packman you ever
see him
no I've heard that name though what is
what is he oh
I don't know I I have a YouTube uh
subscription so I just watch different
things on YouTube and this he seems like
he's a kid I don't know how old he is
everybody looks like a kid lately to me
but
he's like a young guy and he he talks
politics he's like a commentator and
he's really good and I'm just wondering
who he is and what he's done I end up
watching everything he does
I think you can subscribe to his channel
which I don't do like I don't pay for it
I get the free feed do you give him a
like or anything do you do anything
he likes that I don't like anything
but I do like the guy just not giving a
like that's so dumb like give me likes